our society faces many challenges in
particular in the area of youth
unemployment we need to create jobs for
young people they need to acquire skills
and improve their skills which is why
support the whole project of the youth
guarantee hence the need to extend the
funding to extend the whole scheme we
got two billion today for the individual
countries in particular through the
European Social Fund and I think as a
result we have created real chances for
young people to find jobs in Europe and
to re-skill or upskill we discussed the
state of play of the posting of worker
directive Europe is at a crucial
juncture and that many of our citizens
are concerned about the fairness of the
single market the groundwork has been
laid thanks to the intensive efforts of
the Slovakian presidency enabling us
hopefully to come to a good agreement
soon in the interest of a deeper and
also a fair internal market the
Commission message is clear we have to
redouble our efforts along the lines of
witches triangle of investment
structural reforms and responsible
fiscal policies this year we proposed to
sharpen the focus on social fairness we
need to deliver more inclusive growth
for the direct benefit of our citizens
will call for more sustainable all
systems bearing in mind that the
expenses of health systems are expected
to double by 2050 if reforms are not
undertaken European Union health
ministers were reassured by Commission
that the European reference network are
well on track as from 2017 European
reference networks will bring relief the
person suffering from radiuses by
bringing together patients with highly
specialized expertise from across de
make sense to hold the health as part of
economic semester and a hand subject of
country specific recommendations today I
encouraged health ministers to promote
better understanding that the health
should be seen as priority in all
political sectors and of course be
active in political discussions on
health in European semester